hey everyone this is kevin from the test
website comm and today we are continuing
our coverage of the 2017 u.s. Chess
Championship yesterday we looked at
Wesley so getting a victory Nakamura
also got a victory so they are tied at
the top with one point going into round
two and we're out two we have two
players White's going to be played but I
got to come ski forty two-year-old
four-time champion of the US Chess
Championship most recently in 2014 so
not too long ago three years ago winning
this chess championship in the United
States and his opponent is going to be
vada Cobian 33 years old timp highest
rated player in the United States his
favorite player is Petrosian loves the
French descent and as you guessed it he
does play the French defense in today's
game
so Thomas starts out with pawn to e4 and
he's met by the French defense pawn to
e6 don't see this all too often pawn d4
pawn d5 and I along with everyone else
kind of expected the normal Knight to c3
because that's what pretty much everyone
else plays but God I decided to play
something differently play Knight to a
d2 this is the Thomas variation
something you don't see that often at
the highest level play usually you're
playing Knight to c3 it's a little bit
more of an active square when you're
developing your Knights you're looking
to hold control over this square here on
e4 but you also want to attack your
opponent a little bit here on d5 the
Knights of d2 does still defend this a
few things it also does is allows you to
push forward with pawn to c4 or if
you're night here on c3 does not allow
it to do that but one thing you can
notice is it does block the development
of this dark square Bishop here on c1 so
later on if gotta calm ski does want to
get the start square Bishop involved
he's going to have to use a tempo from
his knight to move so that he can get
this involved to the pawn chain but you
could play a pawn to c3 if he wanted to
he could try to exchange off the board
on pawn to c4 and then after there's an
exchange could bring his Bishop involved
into the action so it does have some
options but this is not an opening that
I really expect to see at this high
level so interested to see how both
sides attack this pawn to c5 from vaad
and so there's a few options as far as
how white
wants to attack this he could just
develop his night here to f3 he could
decide to go in exchange off the cinema
he decides to go for the Knight to f3
and then the pawn takes on d4 pawn takes
on d5 and then the Queen recaptures does
not want to go with the pawn recapturing
on a d5 because after white recaptures
there's just going to be this isolated
pawn that Sarah the board and it's going
to be very difficult for black to hold
on to that so correctly decides to go
ahead and recapture with his Queen here
and then Bishop to c4 gaining a tempo
move getting ready to castle on the
Kings side I recognize that his
opponents going to have to move his
Queen back so Queen back here to d6 y
continues castling on the King side
nicey c6 both sides just continue
develop a normal pace I would say rook
here to e1 semi open file getting his
rook involved to make sure he's
attacking also make sure there's no
shenanigans this pawn can't really
capture anywhere because it is being
pinned down right now to the King on e85
some work to do to make sure that he can
castle fairly soon decides to go ahead
and start doing that with Knight to f6
Bishop to e7 should be coming shortly
after this Knight to b3 so this is the
the first move we're right decides to go
ahead and start to attack this pawn on
d4 got a copy is down a pawn in material
but it's going to be very easy for him
to get this material back you know black
can't defend this with a move like pawn
to e5 because then you could just see
the knight take here on e5 if the knight
recaptures on e5 then pawn to f4 this is
being pinned down because the the knight
can't move the rook would just take the
King illegal move so you can kind of see
that there's no real good way for black
to hold on to this pawn and so that's
kind of why he decides to not even try
to hold on to it he knows it's going to
fall so he decided to go and play pawn
to a6 getting ready to push forward with
pawn to b5 starting attacked here on the
Queen side trying to break up some of
the central control that white has on
the server the board compy pushes
forward Poinsett a4 first thing you want
to be doing is looking for what your
opponent's trying to do he toes right
away with his opponent's trying to do
and so he puts a stop to that with pawn
here to a4
Vardhan plays Bishop e7 Knight takes on
DeForest we talked about Knight takes
Knight recaptures and then castle on the
King side and both sides for the most
part have good development they have
double Bishop pairs the board is very
very open especially for French defense
which a lot of times can get clogged up
and then the board both sides don't want
to exchange off a lot sometimes and so
this is opening up the door for some
fireworks later on White has good
control of the center of the board with
his Queen and his rook so all I would
say White has a slight advantage but
both sides fairly equal on kind of their
board say right now
pawn to b3 just solidifying the pawn
chain a little bit also opens up the
door for this Bishop here on c1 to get
involved into the action rook to d8 so
black starting to put pressure on the
center of the board knowing that that's
where everything is going to happen for
the next 10 moves or so
Bishop to a b2 holding down the fort on
knight on d4 it could have also played
Bishop to a3 I think this forces of you
know black to make a decision here
making his Queen move this is what I
would prefer but decides to go and play
Bishop here to b2 Queen c5 opening up
the door for pawn to e5 just more and
more pressure on the square here on d4
Queen up here to d3 I'm not sure what
get a calm sea is looking to do with
Queen to d3 I don't think it improves
its position all that much but instead
of playing pawn to e5 which I thought
for sure is what we're going to see I
think that's why you played as Queen to
c5 looking at the center the board kind
of what else is there going on var plays
upon 2 H 6 which is met by pawn to h3 so
both sides really want to make sure that
there's no intrusion here on the g5
square and white wants to make sure
there's no shenanigans with Knight here
to g4 or the bishop later on coming down
here to g4 as well now the Queen comes
back up here to c7 wants to be a little
bit safer square but if we go back and
say you know what if instead of that
pawn to h6 what if we did see pawn to e5
what might that have looked like okay
well now listen Black has the majority
in the center of the board this Knight
is being pinned down he can start to
attack and so we could see Bishop to a3
forcing the Queen to move clean up here
to c7 now the bishop takes on e7 Queen
recaptures now Knight to f5 attacking
the Queen this is a discovered attack on
his own queen but she could queen ditzy
7 Queen over here to f3 Bishop takes on
f5 I think all in all this is going to
be a good spot for black he does have a
more advanced pawn here in this area the
board with pawn to e4 he has the rooks
that he can control this easily
this nights in a great square so
although I think this was a better play
from black but decided to go and play
with the pawn to h6 punish 3s we talked
about and then Queen here to c7 gonna
copy and now plays a queen back here to
e2 making sure that he doesn't have his
Queen exposed here from the rook on d8
wants to later on play rook to d1
control the center with his rooks allows
Queen to kind of roam free and do what
he wants to Bishop down b4 so doing a
good job of getting his bishops really
involved into the action controlling a
lot of the squares that white wants to
be controlling and then rook to d1 so
got a cop's kid would rather have his
rook here on e 1 and d1 but he's forced
to kind of move this rook over here to
d1 and 4 now this work on a1 is not
doing as much as you would like it to do
now that's real piece that black needs
to get involved into the action is his
life score bishops that's way start to
do Bishop here to d7 rook up to d3 he
knows that he needs to get it to other
rook involvement of the game he can
start to bring his rook here on d3 over
to the king's head if you won't start an
attack you guys have both of his bishop
lined up against his opponent so both
sides starting to get very very
aggressive on board since we don't have
any exchanges both sides have all the
material they need for a very very
strong attack paneer to a4 since we have
the Knights and the bishop and the Queen
all lined up on the center of the board
really needs to go ahead and play this
pawn here to e5 to break up some of that
central control so pawn here to e5
protecting the knight so that's going to
move back here to f3 and now we see even
more material attacking this
on the ponds pretty much forced to come
here to e4 it is a fort here attacking
both the rook and the knight and this is
where things start to get a little bit
crazy we see the bishop take on f6 and
then the pawn takes on d3 and from here
White's in a tough spot if you want to
pause it there's so much going on it's
very difficult to find the best move in
this position now technically the best
move is Queen to e4 this actually stops
the pawn from taking out f6 if this were
to happen then the Queen could come here
to g6 which is a nice little move if you
can see that this pawn is being pinned
down by this bishop and this is a force
check bait until the King comes here to
h8 can't really come here to f8 because
it's just going to be checkmate in one
so it becomes here to HH you see a lot
of force moves from white here and then
at the end of the day it is going to be
a checkmate once this Queen kind of
clears the action so that's going to be
made not sure if going to comes he
didn't see this line it is definitely
hard to find but if we look at instead
say you know Queen to e4 then the pawn
takes maybe he was seeing it really his
best option here would be Bishop takes
on f7 and then if the the King were to
take then the Queen just wings over here
to b4 but really that's just stopped by
pawn takes on c2 getting ready to
promote with this pawn down here to see
one there's no real way for white to
have a good game in this position so
maybe you saw this and said yeah I can't
just go ahead and exchange here and
after I take my Queen it's going to be
bad so that's not going to be an option
another thing he could have looked at is
you know maybe Queen takes on d3 this is
probably the safest line I think black
could now take on h3 and so this is a
discovered attack on the Queen right
here so how does he go from there he
could play Queen to g6 same concept as
before it is being pinned down right now
but then just Bishop back here to f8 we
could
upon take on h3 right now I think this
is fine for white if he doesn't want to
play is queen up here to g6 maybe with
the discovered attack he wants to take
with his bishop here on d8 okay
after the rook takes now Queen here to
e3 I think this is fine black definitely
has a good game but I think this is the
safest play for white if he wanted to
continue in this matter if we were to
try something else let's say he doesn't
want to take with his you know after the
bishop takes and the pawn takes he could
decide to go Bishop takes on d3 this is
one option and now the pawn takes on f6
but then queen up here to e4 not a lot
of other great options Queen down here
c5 and it starts to get a little tricky
as far as how white gets that material
back we do see a rook advantage here a
white could get some material back on
the pond so after the King comes here to
f8 we see the Queen take all in all this
is going to be really good for black
since he does have the two rooks getting
into the in game with a lot of open
space for those rooks to to really
really dominate the game get a compass
key didn't really find any of those even
the less good move of the the bishop
takes here on d3 he found it a pretty
weak move but I understand it's a really
tough position he wouldn't decided to go
ahead and play Bishop takes on d8 what
he didn't think about in his position is
that the Queen can come down and take
this Bishop here on c4 and after he
played Bishop to the ACE we see the
Queen come down here and see for and got
a calm ski actually resigned in this
position so we'll kind of look at why
this is so bad and why he decided to go
and respond it's actually pretty bad for
white we'll kind of look at some of
those variations if we back up a move my
guess is got a calm sea was just
expecting the rook to take your nth that
makes a lot of sense Queen down taking
on c4 is not super intuitive but let's
look at some of the options one would be
pawn takes on c4 very logical to say you
know let's go and take the Queen a but
from here pawn takes on e two and then
there's there's a real threat the first
thing you can see is the rook cap
during this Bishop on d8 but as soon as
the bishop leaves then all of a sudden
the rook can come over here to e8 and
add another defender on this e1 square
first you can have maybe the in-between
move Bishop down here to c3 attacking
the rook rook to be one and then work
over here to e8 we have the bishop and
the rook both honing down on the square
right here on a one block is going to
have a huge advantage this dark square
bishop is not going to be able to
protect this square the only way to
really stop the rook coming over here to
e8 is to lose this Bishop on d8 there's
no way around it so if we come back and
say what if he doesn't take the Queen
what if he decides to go and take this
pawn here on d3
okay well now Queen down here to c3
attacking the rook to really stop this
you could add Bishop to f6 but that's
that's just going to fall right here to
pawn takes on f6 if we have something
instead maybe rook here to be one that's
fine it does protect the rook but now
the bishops just going to fall here on
d8 and that's going to be very very
difficult to deal with going forward
being down a minor piece black still has
the double bishop pair you know Tomsky
just did not recognize he was going to
go down that bishop on that particular
move if instead white decides to kind of
hunker down and say we're going full
defensive mode here we're not even going
to take material Queen to f1 same sort
of logic Queen down here to c3 putting a
lot of pressure with pawn to c2 so let's
say that the bishop does move Bishop to
c7 now pawn just takes on c2 getting
ready to push forward with pawn to c1
could eventually then get his light
square bishop involvement to the game
could bring his dark squared bishop to
another square could as get his other
work involved into the game although
it's going to be very difficult for
white to hold on to this and if he
decides to instead not move his bishop
then as bishop just going to fall here
on d8 so not a lot of great options I
think more than anything gata Kamsky was
just frustrated that he missed that move
and decided that you know let's go ahead
and pack it in and move on to the next
round so
congratulations to you know Vanna Cobian
to come in in began a consequence key
had the white pieces is a huge
accomplishment since he had a drawl in
the first round var is now tied for the
lead with a few other players so
congratulations to him great victory
hopefully you guys enjoyed round 2 we've
had some exciting chess so far lots of
fireworks getting some really aggressive
positions from all players a lot of
these tournaments with the first few
rounds it's just drawers everywhere
people playing super conservative the
same opening everywhere we're seeing
some openings that really don't get to
cover too much and players going for it
and so that's always exciting hopefully
you guys are enjoying we'll have round
three coming up for you in the next day
or two but thanks for watching I'll see
you in the next video